هذه الانفاق والابار الضيقه تلتف حول
اجسادهم النحيله يغوصون في باطن الارض
لعمق قد يصل الى 20 مترا بحثا عن المجهول
بين امل في الثراء السريع وياسين بعدم
الظفر باي شيء انها رحله البحث عن الذهب
في السنغال على مدار 20 عاما ياتي الناسو
افواجا الى هذا المكان في السنغال قبلتهم
هي باطن الارض لما تحويه من المعدن النفيس
التنقيب ولا شيء سواه حتى وان هدد حياه
بعضهم ومرض البعض الاخر السلطات هناك
حاولت منعهم لكن ذلك لم يجدي معهم نفعل ما
دفع الحكومه لتنظيم واتاحه هذا النشاط عام
فسمحت الافراد بالتنقيب عن الذهب يدويا 20
مترا تحت الارض من اجل الوصول الى المجهول
قبل سنوات كانت هذه القريه الصغيره تضم
حوالي 30 كوخا فقط واليوم وبعد الشهره
الواسعه التي اكتسبتها كون ارضها تضم
احتياطيه ذهب كبيرا اصبحت لديها منظومه
اقتصاديه كامله تتمحور حول التنقيب عن
الذهب واصبحت مدينه كبيره لكن هناك قوانين
صارمه في هذا المكان قبل الشروع في الحفر
زعيم القريه يشترط اخذ نصيبه من الغنائم
مثلا وكذلك الحال مع وجهاء القريه وحراس
المناجم ثم مكتشف الذهب
اكل مع بطوله
عمليه الحفر تستغرق اسبوعا كاملا لحفر ما
يصل لعشرين مترا في باطن الارض هنا يتاكد
البعض انه سيحصل على الذهب الى محاله لكن
احد عمال المناجم يقول انها مجرد ضربه حظ
لاكثر وبمجرد الحصول على الذهب يتم غسله
وتنقيته من الشوائب بواسطه الزئبق ثم
الذهاب به بهذا الكوخ المتواضع والمؤقت
الذي يقيم فيه رجل مالي جاء لشراء الذهب
من عمال المناجم يدفع مقابل غرام الذهب
الواحد حوالي 40 يورو اكثر قليلا من السعر
الرسمي للسنغال
على
المصادر تشير الى انه يتم تهريب معظم
الذهب الى مالي لاعاده بيعه هناك وهو ما
يهدد صناعه الذهب في السنغال بالاضافه
لمخاطر سياسيه تخشاها حكومه البلاد هناك
فاغلب عمال المناجم من دوله مالك بان
لديهم خبره كبيره في التنقيب عن الذهب وهو
ما يجعل الماليين متواجدين بكثره في
السنغال اضافه الى تهديد بيئي خطير يتمثل
في استخدام الزئبق في غسل الذهب لانها
طريقه فعاله في التقاط الذهب في حطام
الصخور الا انها ملوثه وسامه وتسببت في
تلويث الكثير من جداول مياه الشرب في
المنطقه